[Musique]
bonsoir mercredi 6 octobre bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 tout de suite
les titres
la réhabilitation du parc des sources de
la bièvre à guyancourt après dix mois de
travaux le lieu rénové a été inauguré
par les élus cette semaine des arbres et
arbustes ont été plantés une aire de
jeux et de street workout ont été
également créés
retour sur le salon autonomic qui s'est
tenue lundi à mardi aux mureaux depuis
cinq ans l'événement est dédié aux
innovations et nouvelles technologies
autour de l'autonomie en 2050 2,2
millions de personnes seront concernées
par la perte d'autonomie en france et
puis tout au long de la saison nous
suivrons la promotion 2021-2022 des
cadets de la gendarmerie ces jeunes
franciliens de 17 à 25 ans vont se
préparer tout au long de l'année où
concours de la profession effectuer des
stages en caserne une vocation pour
certains d'entre vous le verrez premiers
numéros dans cette édition mais avant de
développer ces titres le nouvel épisode
dans la vente du domaine de grignon
l'association grignon 2000 opposé à la
cession des lieux au groupe immobilier
altarea cogedim a saisi le tribunal
administratif de versailles un recours
contentieux au motif que cette vente
aurait dû faire l'objet d'un projet de
loi préalable en raison des critères
écologiques de la forêt et depuis
l'annnonce par l'état de la vente
altarea cogedim plusieurs associations
plusieurs mobilisations se sont tenues
et demandant un autre avenir pour le
domaine grignon 2000 porte par exemple
un projet de centre agronomique
internationale sur place un premier
recours gracieux avait été déposée en ce
sens mi septembre la vente qui pour le
moment est suspendu pendant deux mois en
raison de non respect du code de
l'urbanisme
la commune de thiverval grignon aurait
dû bénéficier d'un droit dit de priorité
pour le rachat de ses terres
[Musique]
je vous disais dans les titres à préty
après dix mois de travaux le parc des
sources de la bièvre à guyancourt a été
réhabilité il nous nous y aura une
opération cette semaine en présence du
maire de la commune et du président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui a financé cette rénovation
les précisions dans ce sujet de bixente
mayence insisté ban patrick jacques de
dixmude et la voix de céline charme
paris s'il vous plaît
un lever de rideau attendu par
guyancourt et saint quentin en yvelines
après dix mois de travaux le nouveau
parc des sources de la bièvre s'est
dévoilé de 1600 mètres cubes de remblais
pour combler l'ancienne fontaine mais
aussi un espace de street workout 240
mètres carrés cette inauguration surtout
les travaux on les attendait depuis
assez longtemps maintenant on avait
refait semaille des sols qui est
magnifique alors certes il a été
totalement terminée l'an dernier mais
les travaux ont duré près de trois ans
et puis on avait cette petite partie là
entre le maïdo sol et la roseraie un
mari de mme anne marie do qui restait un
espace a également été inaugurée sous le
nom de place de la république
aujourd'hui en plus anniversaire de la
vème république
je crois que c'était important et c'est
important effectivement notamment et on
nous l'a fait remarquer que cette place
et une plaque et une plaque bien
visibles parmi les vocations de ce parc
rénové l'environnement avec la
plantation d'une soixantaine d'arbres
c'est un beau symbole
et donc de de végétalisation de deux
espaces pour faire du sport et dieu sait
si lui en cours dans saint quentin va
aussi être porteur de ce merveilleux
message international mondial que que
sont les jeux olympiques de stimuler les
gens à faire du sport à se bouger à se
promener à achat la compétition des
travaux soutenus par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines qui ont coûté
800 10000 euros au total
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines toujours
l'île de loisirs ne bénéficiera plus des
subventions du département des yvelines
vendredi dernier les élus de la
collectivité ont voté cette décision qui
prendra effet au 1er janvier 2022 le
conseil départemental qui donnait en
moyenne 460 6000 euros par an sera en
dehors du syndicat mixte d'études
d'aménagement et de gestion qui gère le
site pour justifier cette décision le
président du département déplore un
problème de gouvernance qui concerne
toutes les îles de loisirs en
ile-de-france dont les investissements
sont prises en compte directement par la
région le site de saint quentin en
yvelines inquiète par son lourd déficit
qui ne cesse de se creuser
791 milles euros en 2019 plus d'un
virgule 9 millions d'euros en 2020
aujourd'hui 1,3 million de personnes
sont concernées par la perte d'autonomie
une thématique qui va prendre de plus en
plus d'ampleur dans les prochaines
années aux mureaux un salon entièrement
dédié à cette problématique se tient
depuis cinq ans autour des innovations
et des nouvelles technologies it onomie
s'est clôturé ce mardi retour avec
mélanie poker patrick jacques de dixmude
voici parrot au delà de ces mignonnes
études se focaliser est aujourd'hui
présente dans 300 établissements
français créé et développé au japon il
est distribué par une société en
deuxième on va l'utiliser auprès de
différentes populations donc la personne
âgée sur par exemple de la maladie
d'alzheimer et troubles dégénératifs ou
alors même des troubles d'agressivité il
est là pour apaiser pour calmer ou pour
accompagner des soins qui vont être
peut-être un peu douloureux ou des
approches peut-être difficile comme une
ou trois mais d'une cinquantaine
d'exposants s'est rassemblé lors de la
5e édition du salon hit onomie
appartements équipés de domotique vente
et location de matériel d'accessibilité
le numérique faut il faire très
attention ça peut être un très bel outil
d'appui mais sait pas ce qui va gérer
réellement l'indépendance parce que la
dépendance ça va aussi bien dans la
santé ça va aussi bien dans l'habitat ça
va aussi bien que dans l'immobilité mais
la question est de savoir comment 24
heures sur 24 on sera en contact
permanent avec les indépendants et c'est
toute la question aujourd'hui de la
notion du maintien à domicile en 2015 la
france métropolitaine comptait entre 400
mille et un million cinq de personnes
âgées en perte d'autonomie vivant à
domicile quand les seniors restent à la
maison et qu'ils sont
rien n'est adapté en fait c'est là où
tout prend de la place le lève malade
tout ça c'est vrai que c'est encombrant
matériel et là c'est vrai qu'il ya des
structures pas en plus lui qui m'ont
tous ont déjà ça c'est un c'est quelque
chose en moins déjà qui prend moins de
place on va dire on a des souvenirs ça
c'est sûr on a quand même habitué à pas
mal de choses et faire un changement il
faut bien y réfléchir c'est toujours
intéressant de saintes on va dire entre
guillemets de s'instruire parce qu'on ne
sait jamais de quoi demain sera fait
surtout quand on est moins jeunes pour
les yvelines selon une étude de l'insee
d'ici 2050 le nombre d'habitants âgés de
75 ans et plus pourraient atteindre près
de deux cent mille personnes
et ce soir sur tv 78 d'ailleurs le 7-8
société sera entièrement consacrée à la
thématique de l'autonomie émission
enregistrée au salon autonomie c'est à
18h30 et s'est présentée par mélanie
poker la suite de notre dossier de la
rédaction consacré cette semaine aux
plans en france relance dans les
yvelines l'exemple ce soir dans ce
journal d'une association ayant
bénéficié du plan installé à trappes en
virée 9 des appareils électroménagers
elle a bénéficié de 12000 euros justin
brasier et gabriel montrant
vous montrer on va rentrer dans dans les
ateliers en battant parme ans remonte la
chaîne de production à l'envers
collecter trier et rénover des appareils
électroménagers usagés voilà la mission
de l'association envie attrape le but
revendre les produits en ligne ou en
magasin 50% moins cher que le prix du
neuf dans le cadre du plan relance les
locaux trappistes ont bénéficié d'une
subvention de 12 mille 292 euros une
somme qui vient s'ajouter à d'autres
aides de l'état un budget qui servira à
l'achat de véhicules électriques et
permettra l'agrandissement et
l'aménagement des ateliers de réparation
derrière moi
on a commencé à réinstaller à un magasin
de pièces détachées d'occasion donc
c'est important pour nous dans nos
process d'utiliser un maximum de pièces
issues du réemploi et les subventions
nous permettre de réaliser complètement
cet espace de l'équipe et de
l'informatiser et d'avoir une gestion
beaucoup plus rationnelle et numérisés
deux femmes deux pièces détachées ici
environ 4500 appareils sont rénovés
chaque année ils sont collectés auprès
de distributeurs ou chez des
particuliers
larry page a lieu en matinée les
produits sont triés ceux qui sont gardés
sont envoyés en atelier pour être réparé
tous les appareils que nous avons jugé
réparable aussi bien sur un point de vue
d'aspect
pas trop abîmer quoi après tout ce qui
touche à la mécanique ça c'est pas un
problème
donc ils sont mis dans la zone qui se
trouve derrière en attente de réparation
ensuite sa part dans les ateliers un
travail effectué principalement par des
salariés en insertion
une quarantaine d'opérateurs cherche et
répare les pannes des machines jetés
sont souvent recyclables le client
rejette parce qu'il ne connaît pas
la panne pour réussir marche pas il
jette pour nous c'est plus approfondie
dans ce camp lorsqu'on recherche pour
ainsi réparer la machine dans les
yvelines une trentaine d'associations
comme envie à bénéficier du plan france
relance
le sport est une première journée
prolifique pour les pistards français ce
mardi aux championnats d'europe c'est à
c'est en suisse en ce moment trois
médailles ont été glanées par les
athlètes pour la journée de la
compétition qui se déroule dans la ville
de grand je cherchais le nom de cette
ville certains s'entraînent dans l'année
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines valentine forte en 1 22 ans
a inauguré la soirée avec une belle
médaille d'argent au scratch 40 tours de
piste conclue par un sprint
la française a même un temps touché l'or
remporté finalement par la britannique
katie archibald thomas boudât lui a
décroché en bronze le gros sur l'épreuve
par élimination il a longtemps mené les
débats avant d'être battus dans l'avant
dernier sprint une troisième place au
final derrière le russe sergei rostov
sfef et le portugais joao mathias et une
médaille d'argent en plus amer en
revanche pour la vitesse par équipes
avec ryan hellal sébastien vigier et
timmy gillon au poste donné de démarreur
une course conditionnée par un faux
départ et une entame manquée et victoire
donc des pays-bas champions du monde
champions olympiques en titre qui ajoute
donc une nouvelle la distinction à leur
palmarès pléthorique ce mercredi soir
débute à athènes les rencontres
mondiales de sport d'entreprise ce et
jusqu'à à dimanche 27 entreprises ont
envoyé certains de leurs employés
sportive dans leur discipline parmi eux
ludovic dumas nicky et rugbymen dans le
club de plaisir il a été sélectionné par
son entreprise une rencontre signée
scénique charles rugbyman le soir
commercial le jour ludovic de manille
fait partie des 160 employés
sélectionnés par l'entreprise véolia
pour participer aux rencontres mondiales
de sport d'entreprise à athènes sa
discipline le rugby à 7 toutes les
entreprises qui veulent inscrire des
sportifs qui sont dans leur entreprise
quel que soit le sport il ya plein sport
il ya du tir à l'arc du basket du foot
du hand du deux volets du rugby à 7 mais
160 sportif veolia à partir à thème ce
sportif qui va fêter ses 45 ans la
semaine prochaine à 35 années de rugby
derrière lui trois ans d'ancienneté dans
l'entreprise c'est via filiale de veolia
qu'il a sélectionnés pour participer
spécialisé dans le traitement des huiles
de vidange usagers et la gestion des
déchets spéciaux elle participe à la
compétition depuis plusieurs années
c'est veolia qui on voit tous les quatre
ans une délégation sur différents stores
ce que le format des mondiaux c'est
c'est un format jeux olympiques en fait
donc j'ai rempli le formulaire en fait
c'est un espèce de recrutement sans cv
en fait donc selon mon parcours sportif
donc j'ai été contacté pour pour être
sélectionné participer à cette belle
aventure au total huit français et trois
anglais font partie de l'équipe ils ne
se sont jamais rencontrés mais vont tous
représentez l'entreprise dans
l'entreprise on fait partie d'un groupe
d'une équipe ce qui peut ce qui peut
être retranscrit
aujourd'hui chez c'est via fait partie
de partie d'une entreprise on c'est un
travail d'équipé je pense qu'il est très
très serviable très cohésion d'équipé et
je pense que ça c'est une réalité pour
le sport surtout quand on fait un sport
collectif et tout le monde compte sur
lui même si voilà les années passent ces
on reste toujours compétiteurs donc je
vais pas là-bas pour faire le touriste
c'est si on peut ramener quelque chose
ce serait avec grand plaisir et grande
fierté ah bah il n'a pas le choix il
faut qu'ils nous rapportent quelque
chose
et puis ce reportage avant de refermer
ce journal devenir gendarme ou exercer
dans le domaine de la sécurité c'est
l'objectif est de 70 jeunes franciliens
qui ont signé le 27 septembre dernier à
la sorbonne à paris leur engagement de
cadets de la gendarmerie ce dispositif a
été mis en place en 2010 7 et permet aux
17 21 ans de se préparer au concours de
la profession mais aussi d'effectuer des
stages en caserne et nous allons les
suivre tout au long de cette étape de ce
parcours premier numéro ce soir avec le
début leur aventure qui va durer donc
une année scolaire et nous sommes allés
les rencontrer avec célia gars de 100 go
[Musique]
alors je vais me présenter et ensuite on
va se présenter en te laisseras tu peux
te présenter ensuite andrea est élève en
terminale ce matin elle se prête à
l'exercice de l'entretien son ambition
devenir cadets de la gendarmerie
pourquoi le gendarme parce que j'ai
aussi des personnes dont 20 femmes x
militaire la jeune femme répond aux
questions des deux membres du jury
devant elle une gendarme et un
professeur 15 minutes pour parler de son
projet et convaincre de sa motivation je
me retrouve dans laquelle à la
gendarmerie parce que plus tard
j'aimerais le gendarme et c'est quelque
chose qui m'a toujours intéressé je
pourrais apprendre de nouvelles choses
et on va dire améliorer mes compétences
néon 2017 en ile-de-france le dispositif
des cadets de la gendarmerie est un
partenariat entre la gendarmerie et
l'éducation nationale pilotée par une
association la norges hand âgés de 17 à
21 ans les élèves sélectionnés seront
préparés au concours de la gendarmerie
et des métiers de la sécurité publique
et privée au programme de la formation
cours théoriques et stages de découverte
en caserne je suis amené à les préparer
aux concours de la gendarmerie nationale
l'ensemble des concours de gendarmerie
nationale et je suis aussi à mener
les ouvrir à la culture générale au delà
du cadre scolaire voilà sûr on va un peu
plus loin sur la citoyenneté et le
civisme ou l'engagement les valeurs de
la république toutes ces choses là trois
stages au camp militaire de ben dans les
yvelines un premier stage d'intégration
pendant les vacances de la toussaint un
stage pendant les vacances d'hiver et un
dernier stage pendant les vacances de
printemps un dernier stage qui aboutira
sur la remise du diplôme de cadets de la
gendarmerie mais avant cela donc treize
candidats sont reçus le 16 septembre au
lycée jules verne de sartrouville parmi
eux ysaline devenir gendarme est pour
elle une vocation et ça lui tenait à
coeur d'arrivée préparé pour cette étape
primordiale dans la suite de son
parcours j'ai révisé j'ai fait mon oral
devant mes parents devant des amis
devant plein de personnes différentes et
comme ça et gérer une plein de questions
différentes le niveau est très haut on a
des candidats qui sont motivés qui ont
déjà fait beaucoup de stages qui sont
renseignés sur les métiers de la
sécurité notamment le métier de la
gendarmerie
ils sont pas surpris par les questions
donc et il est certain que les premiers
candidats qu'on a pu voir pour nous
c'est c'est un ami c'est super quoi
onze jours plus tard il n'est donc pas
surprenant de retrouver andrea et
isaline parmi les personnes retenues le
27 septembre 70 cas des signes leur
engagement pour l'année une cérémonie
dans le grand amphithéâtre de la
sorbonne à paris
la cérémonie je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'on vivra juste une seule fois
aux nazis
c'est stevo très émouvante et surtout
très encourageante partout cette année
sept lycées font partie du dispositif
dont jules verne à sartrouville et louis
blériot à trappes 120 places sont
ouvertes en ile-de-france contre 35 l'an
passé grâce notamment au soutien de la
région deux cent mille euros pour cette
nouvelle promotion et féliciter parce
que c'est un engagement volontaire donc
ce sont des jeunes qui veulent dédié de
leur temps pour les autres il ya un don
de soi il y avait des qualités
d'altruisme puis découvrir des métiers
qui recrutent qui ont besoin de troupes
et donc ça je pense que c'est gagnant
gagnant pour les 60 places restantes une
seconde session de recrutement va se
dérouler avec les associations
partenaires du dispositif
les cadets ont désormais démarrer leurs
heures de cours en attendant leur
premier stage en internat rendez-vous au
camp militaire de ben pendant les
vacances de la toussaint
[Musique]
mais je vous disais donc on ira
régulièrement prendre des nouvelles de
ses cadets de la gendarmerie voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci d'avoir suivi
cette édition et on se retrouve demain
demain jeudi pour une nouvelle édition
du 7 8 journal belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]